merci la parole est à monsieur eric
straumann merci monsieur le président
monsieur le premier ministre le 8 avril
vous annonciez à cette tribune la
suppression des conseils départementaux
depuis vous avez créé des méga région
sans cohérence en ignorant le besoin de
proximité et les conseils départementaux
sont toujours là mais vider de leurs
moyens financiers
avec la baisse des dotations d'état et
l'explosion des dépenses sociales en
particulier le rsa qui devient une
charge insurmontable
la situation aurait pu se rétablir avec
la promesse du candidat hollande de
faire baisser le chômage
mais le nombre de sans emploi ne cesse
d'augmenter et atteint dans mon
département du haut rhin un taux record
de 10,1 pour cent du jamais vu depuis la
libération
le conseil départemental du bas-rhin est
stigmatisée car il ne peut plus financer
faute de moyens l'hébergement d'urgence
alors qu'il s'agit d'une compétence de
l'état
de nombreux départements sont désormais
en cessation de paiement dans
l'indifférence générale de nos
gouvernants vous aviez évoqué monsieur
le premier ministre la renationalisation
du rsa mais au moment des discussions
budgétaires dans les départements cette
proposition est aujourd'hui au point
mort
ma question monsieur le premier ministre
est simple vous voulez vous toujours la
mort des conseils département promise en
la parole est à madame marylise
lebranchu ministre de la
décentralisation et de la fonction
publique
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
député vous savez très bien que pour la
première fois en 2013 le gouvernement
dirigé à ce moment là jean marc ayrault
a reconnu que l'état n'avait pas fait
droit aux demandes des départements
concernant le financement de ce qu'on
appelle les allocations de solidarité
individuelles de solidarité
c'était en 2013 depuis chaque année 1,6
milliard ont été apportées en plus au
département même si nous avons ensemble
reconnu qu'on n'était pas à l'étiage a
effectivement de la dépense le premier
ministe manuel valls faisant constat
qu'avec 1,6 milliard il y avait encore
des départements en difficulté a proposé
deux choses d'une part la mise en place
d'un groupe de travail avec
l'association des départements en france
pour voir si il fallait mais c'est
important parce qu'on ne peut pas on ne
peut pas décider sans travail et les
sujets sérieusement s'il fallait
remonter le rsa au niveau national ce
qui implique une dépense de l'état vous
le savez mais surtout une négociation
sur les ressources que les départements
auxquels les départements devraient
renoncer donc ce n'est pas simple et
dans un premier temps en attendant le
résultat de ce travail collectif
il a été décidé d'apporter une aide de
50 millions d'euros au département le
plus en difficulté 10 nous à nous aidons
actuellement tous les départements qui
sont en dessous de cet ennemi %
d'epargne brut parce que c'est
effectivement un étiage qu'il ne faut
pas dépasser
mais monsieur le député vous pourrez
nous aider aussi en nous posant les
questions ensemble de l'ue financement
de la solidarité envers nos personnes
âgées et aux personnes en difficulté nos
personnes en situation de handicap
est ce que c'est à la solidarité
départementale de jouer la solidarité
nationale c'est ça le débat public qui a
été ouvert à la fois par ce groupe de
travail et par la mission parlementaire
confiée à christophe sirugue c'est un
grand sujet que la solidarité
j'espère que nous pourrons y répondre
merci